hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to those nights and Rachel's
too now if you remember the joy of
creation this was made by the same
person that made that delightful game
and is the official sequel to those
nights and Rachel's which if you
remember I don't think I actually ever
finished but this one should prove to be
beyond scary beyond anything you've ever
seen before and totally serious a
hundred percent of the time
hello ah faz my favourite drink
fizz hey that's not what you said oh my
day at the new Doug and Rachel's my day
at the new Duncan Rachel's
why'd he why are you shooting an
animatronic at Doug and Rachel's my new
day at Doug and Rachel's with a gun and
grenade
my new day at Doug and Rachel's mine I
don't think I'm gonna enjoy my time at
Doug and Rachel's I just have a funny
feeling about that super void my dude
day
Wilfred Baron and Bonnie are dead all
right
glowy that's a problem hello
[Music]
[Applause]
all right well that's new
well did I hear a bore fee were fee oh
that's moderately creepy oh I feel like
I should mention now that this game was
a games from April Fool's so totally
serious absolutely serious 100% totally
canonical game about what am I gonna get
the grenades you promised me that he
would it's so well made fresh pasta game
is actually pretty good now if there's
an upgrade system I'm gonna be very
impressed
okay all right I gotta choose what to do
with my 256 gigabyte card I'm gonna
choose to unplug you yeah yeah yeah okay
well I didn't get to the end of the
story so you know I really got to retry
that one I gotta try it again give me my
gun give me my deagle really creepy
that's not okay don't like that well
sorry Old Yeller
I had to put
[Music]
all right come get some see in the
darkness like that doesn't help my and
my aim is already the stuff of legends I
know about this because that's good it's
so well me I gotta keep going for it I
gotta get the high score I gotta also
conserve my ammo
I can't miss or else I'll die okay all
right well that's not okay
oh that's not okay all right here we go
all right all aboard the crazy train
I mean the happy trade I am having good
time here
oh you pop oh shooting to come to this
neighborhood wink
babbles if I get up ah body shots aren't
worth as much I've just screwed my high
school no no I wasted a bullet I'm
doomed still bark when they're on the
ground well that's not good you nah do
now dude you bastard no you're coming
down that way oh the bun okay
all right in the bud over here all right
man he's stressful okay I should reload
make sure I have bullets in my gun
I gotta get I gotta get I gotta get I
gotta get our I'm gonna get it oh you're
gonna get it oh oh I'm gonna get to get
it
oh man you know these games from Nixon
have more polish than some triple-a team
no it's just a tipos mission coming down
the hallway but even so it's so good is
that a barking out here whoa better put
you down wash [ __ ] a mist well that's
probably gonna come back and bite me in
the face Oh refill I can refill that's
wonderful I didn't know that I could
refill
over there okay I'm just gonna stay here
[Music]
okay
go home I'm really trying guys I don't
know there's an end of Troy okay all
right I'm all loaded up and I'm ready to
[ __ ] I retract that statement ready to
[ __ ] as much as I thought I was paid and
there's some deviancy on your shots when
you go will you wish you watching a
skill we put skill we definitely don't
let him get back close you got this I
got this we got this all right
I'm ready to clock I'm so ready to [ __ ]
oh whoa no
okay okay okay no I know I don't need to
refill 10 a.m. there's a new record it's
a new county record oh oh oh oh no oh
that's bad oh it's a quiet ride our
it's quiet our study time okay bye good
bye good bye okay oh boy that's not good
okay all right okay I hear bar where it
is barking coming from there you are
okay all right
pretty good good pretty good pretty good
pretty good pretty good no get you
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
waffle do-do-do-do-do it's a barky bark
over 400 foot in your face you are shot
roof equal 400 foot I don't like saying
these things
well I'm singing a song
[Music]
I appreciate the good
okay all right is there an end I don't
know if there's an end it doesn't seem
like there would be an end I think it
seems like it's just endless but uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's that puppet bastard but let me go
to endless
I haven't unlocked endless mode cuz I
haven't beaten story murder [ __ ]
alright I was close I must have been
close let's do it again let's go again
and let's go around the band again let's
go again huh ah that's not a set number
of bullets man thing that's a set number
of times I can refill I think ah so I
should really understand I get it you
can stop yelling at me now I know okay
oh that's not good oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
summer camp are you doing to me what are
you doing what are you doing I'm gonna
reload now anyway I think okay okay all
right well bonus jog down the hallways
with the raccoons
oh [ __ ] house dangerous elmo slobber
knocked it all right it's in I don't
want to do it oh just in case you know
what
oh that's not good for Iowa this is a
problem oh [ __ ]
got it I didn't expect that to work oh
that's another one it's a puppet copter
um
right okay right oh okay I guess I don't
have a time limit or anything - I just
keep shooting and is it is it a quantity
of bullet thing or is it just a quality
of shot things
[Music]
okay all right this is ridiculous quit
being pathetic think the way to do it
but I
[Music]
[Applause]
all right anyway so that was those
nights of Rachel's - apparently there's
an endless mode but I have a funny
feeling it's just the same as the other
ones so give it a try yeah and also if
you want me to go back and finish those
nights at Rachel's one I think I only
did one episode of the first night and I
don't even know if I beat it but uh
there that is there there that is that
is that that is that thing that that is
just you know just it just to give it a
taste of endless motivations it's
probably exactly what I think it's daily
oh I'm just willing to bet that it don't
end you know what I'll just let them
yeah yeah I don't feel like going
through all this again well there you go
if you want to try for bragging rights
you can play this game through the link
in the description below and yeah let me
know how high you score and also if you
want me to see the end of those nights
at Rachel's one let me know about that
but also so thank you everybody so much
for watching as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]